the cocaine Caper at the White House is
blowing over so to speak but it's all a
little too on the nose the Secret
Service officially closing out their
investigation on who left a bag of coke
at the White House
imagine this no suspects FBI lab testing
on the bagging finding no fingerprints
and no DNA evidence and lordy there
weren't any tapes either how'd that
happen however investigators were able
to narrow it down to 500 potential
culprits which is way more Biden family
members than I knew ever existed
lawmakers smell a cover-up
in the white house with 24 7
surveillance and it's in a tubby hole by
a situation where they don't know who to
deliver them I mean the American people
think that's a problem you should get an
answer to the question it just seems to
me in America today anything involving
Biden Inc gets treated different than
everything else another cover-up you
know it's the most secure building in
the entire world you can't go in there
they have facial identification they had
you got to get your Social Security
number every time there's something
strange going on with the President
Biden Norris family or anything
regarding his administration or the
White House no one can ever seem to find
an answer
now that the White House staff is in the
clear they can get back to doing their
job which the media says should involve
keeping Biden from getting sandbagged
staff needs to own his age I'm just
going to be honest I don't think they do
a good job uh helping out the president
yes he's 80. you need to be there for
him and you need to make a pathway and
you sure as hell better make sure he
doesn't fall on a sandbag and I blame
the staff for that you can't have these
video images of the president tripping
or the president like going the wrong
way it's your job to make sure he gets
from one place to another he can handle
the presidency it is amazing when you
look at that because his lips did not
move at all
so
Dana yeah we said this when this
happened like we probably will never
know we'll never know no video no but
like if this had happened on January 6th
if they had found a bag of cocaine on
January since they would have been like
eight different angles of whoever had it
but for some reason it's just down in
the white house where are the cameras
well I don't no I actually think it's
strange it's like the location of this
cocaine was in four it was like four
different places I don't really now it's
been a while since I've been done Coke
and yeah and usually you know I put it
in a different type of bag yes yes and
then you know I don't have to worry
about it so but it's the most secure
building in the world and they don't
have any cameras yeah everyone has a
ring camera there's like three cameras
on my dog right now just to make sure I
know what he's doing at all times
um and the media's lack of curiosity
really is something else could I also
say something about Mika Brzezinski yes
please and her comments there so the
AIDS to the president are not home
health aides yeah okay and yes you can
make sure that the Press president has a
clear path I mean that's a goal for any
president of course but are the aides
supposed to help him up the steps of Air
Force One yeah that does it just doesn't
make any sense to me that they would say
he's perfectly capable of handling all
the decisions but you have to make sure
to hold his hand through everything and
I I also think that if you want to
deliver a message like that you could
just call Anita Dunn directly yeah I'm
sure you have a direct line she just uh
maybe she wants to be his Visiting Angel
who knows America's yes sing it oh man I
don't care I don't know where that is
Jesse you must be insanely Furious right
now what a double standard this is if
you were caught with a bag of coke you
would be in jail I would make sure of it
but in this case it happens in the in
the Biden White House nothing happened I
probably wouldn't go to jail for that
really yeah no definitely not
time offense non-violent offender I'd
probably get off with probation good for
you but this is Hunter's like 16th
if it's on her we're not saying it's
Hunter we hope it's not Hunters because
we hope he gets help our sources say
that Hunter's been living at the White
House he's been living there for quite
some time this looked like a drop this
little cubby was a drop and the key was
missing so either Hunter has the key or
this guy who brought it in has the key
We Believe bicycles is the name of the
dealer and we'll be exploring this
tonight on Jesse Waters Prime Time
Janine knows forensics you can get
Prince or DNA off of a sandwich laying
in a landfill 25 years ago
dust anything off this little baggie
remember contacts racing at the White
House remember when Trump got coded
right and they did these diagrams oh no
no no no one cares there's no contact
tracing at all for the cocaine
every time they can't get to the bottom
of something it helps Democrats the
scotus leaker yes we'll never go the
Epstein tapes Hillary's emails the pipe
bomber it's like everything that can't
get to the bottom of suspiciously and
you know what this does remind me of the
Epstein tapes remember Epstein hung
himself and like every tape was blank
yes like every tape happened to be not
working the same thing here and so
Cheadle the woman that runs the Secret
Service I found out was assigned to Joe
Biden as the vice president so they're
close and so close that remember he used
a Skinny Dip in front of the female
Secret Service agents so she's
compromised she's seen Joe naked we hear
and now she's covering up for him again
we believe what if it had been rice and
Judge Greg it's probably fentanyl
exactly to say like oh you know we're
just gonna give up on the investigation
what is that how secure is this white
house not very this is like compare it
to the January 6 commission the
investigation what they they were
chasing grannies over memes they could
find a grandmother yes six months later
who was hidden under a tree in the
corner in the shade yes okay let me tell
what this case does this case is not
about American Justice I think it
convinces all of America that we don't
have Justice anymore it's about a Biden
cover-up and honestly it's a slap in the
face to every American who has ever
arrested prosecuted convicted and went
to jail for cocaine possession
especially a black American it's a slap
in the face to everyone who's ever gone
to jail for possession of an illegal
weapon okay and for Korea Jean-Pierre to
come out and say it's incredibly
irresponsible you media to ask if we
could exempt the Biden family how
disgusting is it well you know what the
attitude that they all have is that
we're Above the Law we don't have to
answer any questions and they laugh at
us and we thought Hillary was
untrustworthy we thought that these
people I mean they literally blow her
away and to the Secret Service have you
no dignity have you no shame are you
willing to go along with you're either
inept or you're covering up right
because there we already know that karee
jean-pierrez said the bidens were not
there on on Friday we know the bidens
were there on Friday so now we've
tightened the circle of the possible
time with which that cocaine was put
there now why don't you want to drug
test people in the White House excuse me
this is important and number two why are
the cameras not working where are the
canines why don't you know everyone
who's gone through there it's all
hogwash you vacated the building it was
so dangerous when you saw that what you
thought might be Anthrax and now you
don't have anything to say about it so
it's either a cover-up they're a nap and
in addition to drug testing the staffers
I think they ought to stop lying to us
and coming out and saying we know Hunter
was there the reason this is so
important is Hunter doesn't get the plea
deal if they've been pin this on him and
finally why is Hunter Biden always in
our face why is this guy at the White
House why is he on Air Force One why is
he in Ireland why is his idiot State
Department dinners this guy is either a
drug addict or a reformed drug addict we
shouldn't have to deal with him
constantly in our face and if Joe has to
always take care of his son maybe he
ought to teach his son to take care of
his seventh granddaughter and his own
child you know uh uh Harold the results
are inconclusive generally wouldn't you
then just keep looking or expand it I
mean they didn't even they haven't even
looked at cell phones just seems like if
there's you even you must admit there is
it they'll give up much easier in a
democratic White House If This Were in
Trump and I know it's just a cliched
comparison this thing would have just
begun it would have turned the place
upside down well there are two parts to
your question uh
I don't think that this is because that
he's a Democrat or Republican uh but the
first your first question I hope that
this is not it perhaps the Secret
Service will continue I'm not going to
besmirch that organization I think that
that that they probably should go a
little further and if they've narrowed
it down to 500 people there would have
to be cameras to be able to help them
even narrow that number down even
further but
the trust in our society just completely
broken down we I listen to you guys you
guys could very well be right but it's
we Democrats would say Republicans we
should we should go after Trump and do
this if Republicans are going to let the
Democrats listen to members of Congress
say it's just a Biden thing so they're
covering up I don't know but I do think
the the best question you asked to me is
should they keep going and I would
imagine if it's only been a week and a
half or two and you've narrowed down to
500 people to all the points have been
made they ought to be able to find a
camera that can help narrow it down to
the president I honestly think that this
had happened in the Bush Administration
I can imagine like the scenario
obviously it's a hypothetical obviously
um that the president would say there's
500 great call them in yeah one by one
do you have security clean was it you
and make them look everybody in the eye
was it you was it you was it you and
just and what happened to my personal
responsibility where if whoever it is
sorry guys it was me turn yourself in
put everybody out there misery but they
are going to get away with it Secret
Service just gives up but also it could
be the president of the forget the
Secret Service the president of the
United States himself could say I want
an answer and we're not stopping till we
get an answer and he's not doing that
all right so I hope that's not the case
yeah she was asked finally at a briefing
she finally said well yes of course it's
not even about the coke right it's not
even about that it's just it's the whole
principle thing I could give a crap what
people do in their own what is about the
coke if the person has a secure yeah
security clearance because then that's
illegal and also everything has fentanyl
in it and that does you know it does
that's the other question I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now